[Music]
good morning and welcome my name is Ming
I'm the tech lead for the social
platform and an take oh I'm minion I'm a
senior director of engineering at
Niantic we are very excited today as San
Francisco to talk about our story with
spanner how we migrated terabytes of
data from existing database system to
spanner we're ensuring performance
reliability and company-wide buy-in this
is the overview of the topics that we
will cover today I will talk a bit about
Niantic as a company our mission is five
words Adventures on foot with others we
make products that encourage our users
to go outside walk around and explore
the real world around them and also to
have face to face real-world social
interaction with other users many years
ago we started making ingress a game
that has many loyal users and then two
years ago we launched Pokemon go and we
have a very anticipated game coming out
which is Harry Potter Wizards unite our
newest augmented reality real world game
Ming will tell us a bit about his
background again I work in the social
platform team at Niantic my team take
care of the login accounts friendships
and messaging before this job I worked
at a Google on quite a few different
things including API infrastructure
Gmail display ads and server performance
and I'm minion oh so Niantic was part of
Google for some years and then was spun
out into its own company so we are now
an independent company that used to be a
part of Google so I'm a senior director
of engineering at Niantic I oversee the
new Harry Potter game ingress and then
parts of our real world
augmented reality developer platform
including the social piece for example
that this powers the Pokemon go
friendless and trading feature that came
out a couple weeks ago other pieces of
the platform include analytics
sponsorships events and CRM previously I
was founder and CEO of a start-up
evertune that was acquired by Niantic
last year I was CEO of minted and I
spent five years at Google where I
co-founded Google Desktop Search was
tech lead of Gmail ads when Gmail came
out in 2004 I found at Google lively an
avatar chat product and before that I
was at Microsoft for five years and I
was an engineering lead on Microsoft
Flight Simulator so some information
about the problems and challenges that
we face at Niantic in terms of data
storage when we store information using
a geographic related index and there are
many players that converge on one
real-world location this can create hot
spots for our reads and writes of that
data we have periodic events where up to
hundreds of thousands of users will go
to one location or play around the world
in community events and this can cause
spikes of activity for our data storage
and other server systems during those
times and in general we have a high
volume of reads and writes and one extra
challenge is that unlike other products
where users are by themselves
and any lag between users is not visible
even a lag of minutes may not be
apparent to the user in our use case
many users are playing next to each
other and are looking at each other's
phones so we need immediate consistency
because any lag of updates between the
phones will be visible to the users this
is an example of our need for our data
storage and other systems to perform
well at high volume this graph is the
cloud datastore transactions per second
at the Pokemon go launch in 2016 the
orange line at at the bottom is the
targeted the anticipated traffic the red
line is five times that which is the
worst case or best case depending on
your perspective and the green line is
what actually happened so reach 50 times
of actual traffic and there was a need
for the data storage and other systems
to perform well at that scale here is a
diagram of the architecture of our real
world
augmented reality developer platform
there are many different pieces to it
many aspects to what makes a real world
game or applications successful we won't
go through all the pieces here but the
piece we will be talking about today is
social which is near the middle of this
diagram the point behind this diagram is
to indicate how there are many different
teams they each have their own data
storage needs so when we think about
migrating from datastore to spanner
there's different timelines of teams
different API is that they have and
different priorities of each team all
Niantic games and apps are powered by
Google Cloud we started years ago with
App Engine and in recent years have been
using kubernetes engine
we use BigTable and data store and we
are migrating from data store to spanner
which is the content of this talk for
analytics we use bigquery which we
populate with pub/sub and data flow and
in addition we have monitoring logging
and virtual private cloud for these
systems and now Ming will go over the
technical challenge and our approach for
moving from data store this manner
thanks again Ian so now let's talk about
the digital the database system that we
used to stop the player state we started
using datastore to start up our player
state since 2012 when we launched our
first game
ingress it has served us really well in
fact we built our second game Pokemon go
and launch data in 2016 on top of
datastore datastore is a scalable no
Seco database that supports transactions
it is strongly consistent it is queried
by primary key or by ancestors however
the secondary index they are not
strongly consistent they are only
eventually consistent by that we mean
newly created rows may not appear in the
secondary index immediately and the rows
that are modified or deleted may stay in
the index for a short period of time as
you can imagine this could cause problem
to our players for example in Pokemon go
we have this friend list feature where
you can add a player as your friend in
order to do that you need to first fret
a Creator imitation code and the other
player needs to use this code to add you
as a friend
and this imitation code actually goes to
the secondary index of the player table
if the secondary index is behind the
other player wouldn't be able to find
you use the same invitation code you
just provided to him so the other player
has to wait until the secondary index is
populated so we have a lot of experience
on this and we create a workaround which
essentially is a new table that
functions as a secondary index in this
case the table is the imitation code
table and the primary key is imitation
code because for datastore if your query
by primary key is always strongly
consistent this actually solves the
problem of secondary index being behind
however it also brings some problem
because now we have the same data in two
separate tables whenever a game entity
is updated a lot of time the secondary
index table have to be updated too we
build a lot of code just to make sure
the data in both tables are consistent
and this is an error-prone process as
you can imagine as the number of
secondary indexes increase the amount of
code that to deal with this problem is
becoming unmanageable so we are
searching the next generation data
storage that can power our games in the
next five or ten years the following
criteria are important firstly the cost
it has to be as good as datastore in
terms of latency
it must be at least similar or better
than datastore the ability to perform
relational queries an important tool
because with that we can just use a
single query to do more things here is
where spanner come into the picture
spanner is a new database system that's
offered by Google it gets into a status
back in 2017 and we keep a close eye on
this new database system compared with
datastore spanner is also very scalable
and it's a sequel database which means
it allows us to do aggregation joins the
secondary indexes in spanner are
strongly consistent other things we
really like about spanner include a
unique index and cascading deletion
within the organization we had a lot of
discussion about what do we do with this
new storage system do we want to try it
and possibly use it to power all of our
product in the next five or ten years if
yes when do we start
how shall we started
the points from people that are in
doubts including includes the following
data star works just fine for the
current games why are we spending so
scarce and union resources to replace
something that is not broken the
organization has so many tools and
knowledge built around datastore we have
the zero on spanner do we want to go
through the same process of learning
again using a new database system
actually introduces a risk to new
product launches because we have very
little knowledge on this system if we
ever want to migrate the data from
existing system to spanner it'll be a
pretty complex engineering process and
there's a risk associated with that
we also heard the following from people
who are supported working around the
secondary index being still problem is
just becoming so difficult the number of
secondary indices are becoming more and
more and the amount of code that is to
deal with this problem becoming manager
unmanageable this is the one opportunity
we can advance our database system of
database technology to make our system a
lot simpler
we heard Steiner has a great latency I
think we should just try it as a data
science as a data scientist I'm so
excited to be able to use psychic array
to get player Intel's from spanner which
otherwise I have to ask engineers to
write to write data flow to get those
information from data store this is a
new Google product we are going to get a
lot of help from Google side a note on
the data migration so if we ever want to
decide to migrate the existing data to
spanner we are talking about moving
terabytes of data while they are being
changed by active players at the same
time this is again a very complex
engineering process because we need to
make sure all of the data between
datastore and spanner are in sync and we
can't afford any downtime
after a lot of discussion about
trade-offs and risks we have decided to
start with a low QPR system to
experiment with a spanner it is allow
easier to get agreements for one
experiment with low bagged options then
committing to a long term migration
strategy the system that we chose was
the account system the account system is
relatively simple it has lower QPS than
the game and most of the queries are
read-only we have this upcoming feature
called
account linking which allows the player
to log in with both Google and Facebook
credentials if we could build this on
top of spanner we can do it quickly
because we no longer need to write code
to deal with the secondary index being
stale problem
there's also risks the account system is
one of the most critical systems that we
have if the account system is now
working nobody can play our games
relying on data migration Falls spanner
also may delay the launch of account
linking the account system manages all
of the code names and logins for all of
our games it also helps to locate
players for admin tools it is currently
running on the on App Engine and before
the migration the storage is data store
we are going to move it to spanner now
is the data migration process it is
roughly divided into three steps the
first step is copying the data which
means copying all of the accounts from
datastore to spanner the second step is
validation in this step we validate data
between the two repositories and make
sure they are actually in sync the third
step is switching spanner and make it as
the source of choose all of the data we
return to the player will be from
spanner
step one copying the data during this
step we are copying terabytes of data as
they are at the same time they are being
modified by active players so the first
thing we need to do is whatever change
is made by the active players you want
the change to be populated to spanner to
achieve this we use dual rights
we created a transaction listener in the
data access layer of datastore so that
we never account changes by an active
player we copy the whole account to
spanner
so this take care of the changes made by
active players what about the inactive
players we run a data flow to copy all
accounts from data flow to spanner wait
are there any grease conditions yes
because the same data in spanner could
be modified by both transaction listener
and the data flow at the same time so
there could be race conditions to
resolve this we carefully load the data
flow to user insert mutation in certain
fails if the account already exists on
spanner this situation happens when the
active player has already made changes
to the account and therefore the account
is coated by the transaction listener to
spanner so during this process we
continue monitor
spanner latency and throughput to make
sure spanner is working fine with the
data the the traffic from the data flow
by the way the dual rights can be turned
off if needed
step two is data validation this step
lasted for two weeks during this two
weeks we run validation multiple times
the validation is done by a data flow
the data flow reads accounts all
accounts from datastore and spanner and
compare them we do expect some
inconsistent results the reason for that
is just because the the accounts reading
from datastore and the spanner may come
from different timestamp for these
inconsistent results will sample them
and manually check them to make sure
they are actually in sync at the end of
the second week we are very confident
that the data between two repositories
as in sync now we are ready to switch
spanner as the source matures we still
keep writing to datastore because we won
the option to roll back to data store if
anything goes wrong we keep writing to
datastore for another two weeks during
these two weeks we keep monitoring
spanner by reports stackdriver conquers
that it's whatever source we can find if
there's any issue with the new system
running on spanner and the whole
migration process from the beginning to
the end of step three lasted for four
weeks
at the end of the first week we are very
confident that the new system works
properly on spanner
now we can turn off the rights to the
datastore with that we can no longer go
back to datastore easily because the
changes are not populated there anymore
thanks to Google we got a lot of help
from Google cloud support team during
the migration particularly we received
guidance of performance regarding schema
design indexing and Caray we got early
access to the open source spanner backup
tool which allows us to have peace of
mind knowing that if anything goes wrong
we can still go back to work older
version of the data Google Cloud support
team also monitored our spanner instance
during the migration to make sure that
instances performance is working
properly so this is a four week of hard
work to copy the data and validate it
this is the result we are very happy to
see we have a lot better performance in
terms of latency is 25 percent better at
50 percentile and we are very excited to
see there's a cost savings as well the
reason behind that is for datastore it
is charged by by number of accesses
however for spanner is charged by a
number of nodes
after this data migration the whole
company just have a lot more confidence
on the new database system and we are
ready to move more systems to spanner on
top of spanner we launched account
linking in March and friendlist in June
in particular for the front list launch
we modified our data access layer to
work with spanner this allows us to move
existing system to spanner switching the
data storage layer from datastore to
spanner with just changing a few lines
of code here's the QPS to spanner the
red line is from account system and the
blue line is from the funless system the
social platform team launched account
system on top spanner to show how to
migrate data from existing system to
spanner and we launched the fellows
system on top of spanner to show the
spanner is performant and scalable to
support live game traffic from Hakeem
and Gao after the two experiments on
spanner
the whole company is very excited a lot
of teams decided to move their product
to spanner on their own
we now have one team in the process of
moving their product and another team is
in the planning stage so we found that
instead of a continued debate the best
way to convince is started with a small
experiment and expand from there
here are the takeaways from this talk
for data migration we recommend the
following steps start with copying and
your rights
do the right validation switch the
application to the new storage and
finally turn off all regional rights
always have a back-up plan
a rollback plan with that we can always
go back to the state before the
migration if anything goes wrong the one
way to convince the organization to do
experiment is is we start from a low
traffic system and expand from there
you
[Music]